ça rame et beauté merci au public d'être
avec nous chez eux
j'ai pensé à vous tout l'été vous m'avez
manqué de ouf je sais qu'ils vous ont
manqué aussi sont tous là bon faut faire
tous une entrée exceptionnelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il m'a dit un truc que tu adores qui m'a
fait graver marie ce que tu m'as dit un
truc qui ouvent tu m'a dit tu es
contente de revenir pourquoi
ouais cependant de revenir et à tel
point que j'ai même hâte de me prendre
du chocolat
claude van damme est avec le championnat
[Applaudissements]
tu es beau gosse toi prête et jean
t-shirt écoulée mabhouh sa requête que
le paquet qui voit sa mère nom de chaque
ou danton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jean michel maire est très réactif aux
appels de la nouvelle manager des
chroniqueurs alors qu'il répondait
jamais avant
[Applaudissements]
la personne et dans des bassines chargé
en brasse et c'est vrai qu'il paraît qu
autant l'année dernière vous répondiez
très peu aux messages qui sont réaction
m'a beaucoup reproché dernière de
l'abandon je ne sais pas encore si ça
serait cette demoiselle cynthia et c'est
vrai cette année où commence après le
hasard a voulu que ce soit elle certains
garçons stade bayard a su
[Applaudissements]
pas
m
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je commence à flipper je sais pas pour
vous chez vous mais je commence à
flipper parce que ça quand ce vraiment à
chauffer entre la france et le brésil
depuis vous à vous aviez vous avez
compris l'histoire alors ils se sont
embrouillées après il ya le président
brésilien restait pas mal parlé de
brêche à mon moi qu'est ce que je fais
[Applaudissements]
m
avec
en 28
[Applaudissements]
ah oui parce qu'elle est l'icône wiimote
ou pas oui attendez si op oui bonsoir
madame la ministre
bonsoir ça va mais vous mais ça va cette
chez france inter et bah bravo board
aime bien mais je suis en direct
je vous appelle en direct de l'émission
comment comment vous allez si tu te
journée c'est une journée très
importante pour vous aujourd'hui ce
grenelle il est très très attendu j'ai
vu que c'était vraiment top tweets
aujourd'hui dont on ne parlait que de ça
et je vous le dis n'ayez peur n'ayez pas
peur on s'adresse à toutes les personnes
voilà qui sont victimes de violences
conjugales
n'ayez pas peur d'appeler vraiment
parler c'est le plus important des vues
chez bourdin ce matin par action alors
superman ou ça va ça va bono malade on
arrive à joindre les deux bouts coin
c'est paru un peu
il valorise le québec je les vois mais
moi j'avais pas envie de les voir mais
me disait regarde moi regarde y'a un
problème fait des signes de loin c'est
pour faire mes devoirs et gaz et des
gens du public là en face de moi c'est
rigolo ça il était partie des missions
oui amer
[Applaudissements]
brouillés j'arrivais pas comprendre
oui mais bon ça nouveau mordu l'oreille
ça c'est mike tyson a à l'autre bout de
son nez qui s'avère trop quant à elle
voulait m'en de l'oreille à la la la
c'est plus grave que le prix